طبعا بيصر بيسلم يعني
مشاهده الاخبار السلبيه في الصباح يعني
بيخلي الواحد يتوتر في العمل يعني
يخليه مش مركز السوشيال ميديا ما بياثر
اشتغل بصدق وبحب وبنيه طيبه
يعني شغلات كثير حلوه فاكيد نشاطي هيكون
ممتاز ممكن ما بتاثير بالنسبه
الوقت يكون ما يكون مبتذل زي ما بيقولوا
في السوشيال ميديا همم غالبا بتكون يعني
الموضوع هو نفسه هو هو سؤال كان العمل
شخصيه الواحد بتكون في العمل هي نفسها نفس
[موسيقى]
ممكن انت يكون لك منصب اداري ووجودك في
السوشيال ميديا على صفحاتك يكون زياده
مثل ما بيقولوا يعني سبور زياده وكول
زياده فيكون هذه اثر على همم يعني موظفينك
على الناس اللي حواليك ويكون يعرفوك انت
في ههه بعد معين تختلف بالنسبه لهم انا
صراحه
التطبيقات فلا اعلم هذا الشيء يعني